you know the government has no right to
pick through your private information
just because that's technologically
possible and the laws are now so lacks
that they can my name is Mike German I'm
senior policy counsel to the American
Civil Liberties Union and prior to that
I served 16 years as a special agent
with the Federal Bureau of Investigation
there have been a number of significant
changes to the surveillance laws since
911 so much more of our communications
are now broadcast in a way that makes
them much more vulnerable to government
surveillance and interception because of
the way technology has advanced so
rapidly the way our the Fourth Amendment
protections work with your personal
papers you know which requires probable
cause and a warrant before the
government can search your desk to look
through your papers unfortunately now
most of our personal papers are kept on
third-party servers you know it's our
email that's that's stored remotely
every thought that we have we hit the
search engine to find out more about the
subject we're thinking about that all
that gets recorded by third parties and
that information doesn't have the same
Fourth Amendment protections
since nine eleven the government has
become very enamored with this concept
of the value of data and you might
remember a program called total
information awareness that was a
Department of Defense program where the
government wanted to collect all
available data and and to sort of have
it in one place or at least accessible
simply by one organization to where they
could collect all the details about a
person's life and put it together and
and once the public found out about that
they were outraged and it was ultimately
to funded but that mentality has never
gone away and it's actually been
recreated through a lot of different
agencies in the way that they collect
and retain data you know the FBI now has
something called an investigative data
warehouse that in 2008 had 1.5 billion
records in it so you know these huge
data warehouses are are favored by the
government even if they can't use the
information today they think that some
technological algorithm is going to be
developed that will allow them to see
patterns in the flow of data that allow
them to predict future criminal
activities but you know what I've always
told them is if somebody had you know
some kind of process in which they can
predict the future they wouldn't be
selling it to law enforcement they'd be
selling it to Wall Street and they'd be
selling it to Las Vegas
moved away from surveillance based on
individualized suspicion you know the
Fourth Amendment standard of probable
cause and a warrant has basically
evaporated and the government now can
collect information about people it
doesn't even suspect of wrongdoing a lot
of police departments from all levels of
government federal state and local have
combined their efforts their
intelligence collection efforts and
actually set up facilities called fusion
centers and the problem with these
centers is it's very unclear who's in
charge when you have the FBI sitting
next to the department of homeland
security agent sitting next to a state
police officer sitting next to the local
police officer because there are non law
enforcement agencies working within
these centers military private companies
you know their authority to conduct
domestic law enforcement intelligence
gathering is quite questionable once you
talk about military and private
companies and other non law enforcement
agencies being involved in the center
and receiving this information there
it's very inappropriate and can
potentially have private harms come to
people where say they lose their job
because some fusion center report has
suggested that they're involved with a
group it's dangerous when it's really
just a group that has a policy
difference with the government we have a
number of significant sort of
overarching concerns about the the way
law enforcement intelligence
surveillance authorities have expanded
since 911 the first is the excessive
secrecy that surrounds these activities
the way our government is intended to
function is is by having three branches
of government that check one another too
often what we found is leaks to the news
media or actually provide the
information to Congress to let it know
what's happening rather than the
effective sharing of information between
the branches and also when when people
are harmed by these excessive
surveillance programs and try to sue in
federal court the government has claimed
a state secrets privilege to shut down
the entire lawsuit even where there is
evidence that's not
classified that the person could use to
show they were spied on the government
has not allowed these cases to move
forward so you take two branches of
government out of action and it makes it
much harder to check abuse we need to
have accountability over these agencies
because they all have a long history of
abuse and what we've seen so much since
911 is those guidelines have been
stripped away and they're the agencies
are being told you know in this
emergency environment that you know that
that one piece of data out there might
be the key so go get it so so the
overzealousness that gets created leads
to over collection and encourages
excesses rather than reasonable limits
where the government has a reasonable
factual basis to believe that you are
doing something wrong and our threat to
the community of course we all want to
make sure they have the tools to go and
investigate those people but where the
government has no basis for believing
you're a threat it really should leave
you alone you know the government has no
right to pick through your private
information just because that's
technologically possible and the laws
are now so lacks that they can they can
interview your neighbors your colleagues
at work they can do a lot of very
intrusive things including go through
all these commercial databases that has
you know a tremendous amount of
information about you and they can
collect that all up put it in a dossier
and put it in the FBI system even though
through all that work they found you
were no threat whatsoever and we're
doing absolutely nothing wrong and they
can hold that information essentially
forever
you